drôle de moment pour faire une telle
déclaration en plein mouvement des gilet
jaune
eric alauzet débuté lrm se lance dans la
course aux municipales parce que dit il
une crise peut être une opportunité
c'est quand il ya des crises c'est quand
il ya des problèmes qui sortent de
profondément que la société peut être
prête à faire les évolutions qu'on n'a
pas pu faire auparavant
ça permet parfois de décoincer un
certain nombre de choses et et d'avancer
et moi je sais que chaque fois que j'ai
pu avancer c'est chaque fois qu'il ya
des crises eric alauzet adhérents des
verts médecin acupuncteur à siéger au
conseil régional il y à 20 ans puis au
conseil départemental
en 2001 il devient adjoint à
l'environnement de jean louis fousseret
le nouveau maire socialiste de besançon
il siège toujours au conseil municipal
sa carrière politique et d'écoles en
2012 quand il est élu député du doubs
avec le soutien du ps
toujours avec le soutien du ps et les
réélu en 2017
il siège à l'assemblée nationale dans le
groupe lrm aujourd'hui il se définit
écologistes de gauche et veut partir en
campagne avec les progressistes et une
belle réussite de lac-aux-sables ça
correspond à l'image de cette ville de
milan 104 choix tiennent ville de centre
gauche et dans laquelle il ya souvent eu
des personnalités de droite qui ont
siégé
mais peu importe vous ne mettriez
l'étiquette marche je suis en marche
donc ça c'est de la cuisine interne il
ya une procédure mais c'est pas
forcément ce qui intéresse à mon avis
nos concitoyens ce qui intéresse nos
concitoyens c'est le projet qu'on va
porter pour pour ce territoire
eric alauzet dit vouloir jouer la carte
du rassemblement avec une méthode de
démocratie contributive selon son
expression
avec cette candidature il lance vraiment
la campagne des élections municipales à
besançon 15 mois avant le scrutin
au fond c'est le même notre démocratie
interrogé sur le même
un dollar